[Music]
when we were kids one of us was allergic
to cats and dogs so in order to not
ostracize that one kid my parents said
we were all allergic i was kind of
crushed by this because i love the idea
of having a
furry yeah for i was i was a furry when
i was a kid
uh a furry friend a furry pal and uh so
the next logical step was to get rabbits
and i remember going to the pet store to
get a rabbit i brought it home but it
was hopping oddly and i picked it up and
looked underneath it and
realized that it didn't have hind feet
it just had these two
little nubs so i brought it back to the
pet store owner um and he said all right
why don't you pick out another one and
he took it
kind of aggressively and tossed it into
a separate bin and i said well what's
going to happen to that one and he said
oh one of the snakes is going to get
lucky
and so i said well okay you know i can't
have that happen so i said can you at
least give me a discount on it and he
he said i'll tell you what i'll knock
off five bucks
so he gave it to me for 15 instead of
20. and then right when you left this
store with nubs he went on to feed the
snakes a bunch of able-bodied
rabbits
snakes have to eat
they're like this one doesn't have feet
oh good this one has fear
the legs are my favorite this is really
my lucky day
life could be a dream life could be a
dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your two-legged host justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
uh with me as always is uh
this christian who also has there's also
a biped yeah yeah you are a biped such
you know both have to be bipeds
um
happy ending i ended up having nubs for
god
into college like well into college so
like seven or eight years which is long
i was with you that day when you uh
tried to return
nubs
and do you remember when we were heading
home this is we're dating ourselves here
because when we were driving home
the popular song on the radio at the
time was that natalie imbruglia song
torn remember that
remember it
well that's what we named the rabbit on
the way home because that song was
playing do you remember we named her
natalie oh because that song was playing
on the radio i'm already done and then
but nubs ended up sticking because you
know no short one syllable natalie is
kind of a kind of a mouthful it's much
more fitting yeah i mean it looked much
more like a nubs
and not only did we have nubs for how
many
years seven eight years we had a series
of
uh
problematic
yeah well rabbits we had alice who was
alice was our first rabbit first rabbit
she was
cute
but very cute but we got it from one one
easter she was a little strange i
remember waking up on easter morning and
there was a rabbit in my bedroom and
then this was our first rabbit and named
alice and she was a white rabbit that
looked cute but
she had problems she she would run
around in circles she wouldn't move uh
in a straight line so she would run
around in circles and make this buzzing
kind of annoying buzzing sound yeah she
had i think a neurological problem uh
because she would her head was
constantly cocked to one side and she
would favor that side when she ran so
which is why she ran in circles because
she was constantly i think she was
trying to go straight but her head was
but she would also remember the worst
thing she did she would uh
i mean she would they're just [ __ ]
everywhere i mean there was my our poor
mother was like beside herself oh
speaking of uh rabbit [ __ ] everywhere oh
yeah do you remember yeah i know what
you're gonna say what you
used to do to me when i was a child
so my two older brothers would um to
torture me
they would one of them would would hold
me down and the other would cover my
eyes and pinch my nose awful this is
awful
making my mouth open and they would feed
me what they said was rabbit poop it
wasn't that cruel because it wasn't
rabbit poop a little because rabbits
make little pellets for poops and they
would say
uh i'm this is rabbit poop you're eating
rabbit poop and i'd you know be fighting
as much as i could but i would have to
have this rabbit poop in my mouth and
come to find out they weren't feeding me
rabbit poop thank god but there was
ostrich poop but
they were feeding me rabbit food these
little pellets which which is roughly
the same size as rabbit poop
still not good it's still not good yeah
when you're when you say
you're feeding someone rabbit poop you
should instead be feeding them currants
or something anyway
uh our guest today loves rabbits
[Music]
so so the reason we're talking about
rabbits extensively um is because our
guest today
is it's hard to separate
her from
her love of rabbits she often talks
about how much she loves her abs she
used to go on letterman and and
her pet rabbits i remember were a major
topic of conversation she's a rabbit
enthusiast yeah that's fair to say and
to the point where if you say something
somewhat disparaging about one of her
rabbits she'll get very defensive yes
she is uh
such a
unique human being yeah i may be the
most unique human being i've ever known
she's up there yeah so our guest is amy
sedaris
who is um
a strange
colorful
fascinating person rabbit owner rabbit
owner rabbit enthusiast as you said and
um just a a a performer i don't even
know how to la amy's one of those people
that it's hard to
label her really it's hard because she's
an actress she's she's a writer she's
just a performer i mean she's just an
interesting god bird i was introduced to
her years ago when i was in college she
was on a show called strangers with
candy where she played so good a student
a high school but as an adult jerry
blanc jerry blank she played a character
called jerry blank who is an older woman
who um
who was in school i was in high school
and i remember my
roommate john in college had an
autographed
poster
picture rather framed of uh amy playing
jerry blank as jerry blank and it was
and it was made out to him and it just
said john
pee on me
love jerry
and i
i thought that was stuff it was right
above his bed i remember and i thought
it was the funniest thing that but and
now knowing her a little bit it's so
funny to think of her
doing that autographing this so
funny she is so
weird and fearless you guys worked
together on a movie called ghost team a
few years ago was that the first time
was that the only time you've worked
with her yeah no i i didn't meet her on
that i had met her because we have
mutual friends um
i saw i've known her for a long time but
i really got to know her well on ghost
team yeah that was the first time we
worked together i think and then we a
couple years ago we went to uh we hung
out with her in her apartment in new
york
justin and i we went to her apartment
and
we got stoned in her apartment and it
was it's such a few fascinating place to
be with the rabbits and
and the knickknacks everywhere it was it
was like art directed yeah that place it
was it was such a fascinating place and
uh really funny really funny time but
she talks about her um
the the knickknacks that she surrounds
herself with and and uh
and for lack of a better word i wouldn't
know what else to call them but she's
she all of those things have an
important
level of importance to her that they're
all she's not like a hoarder she's she
creates a lot she is really into like
crafting we get into it um a little bit
in the episode but uh she's she's really
loves giving people gifts um and she'll
make her own things she's a very she's
crafty she's crafty she's like
really like a kid like a
interesting little kid uh we should also
mention really fast that she is on uh
she has her own show now called at home
with amy sedaris that gets nominated for
awards it's it's a hilarious uh sort of
variety show i guess you'd say yeah so
you'll you'll uh we'll talk about that
we'll talk about uh instagram and and
rabbits and everything in between mostly
rabbits yeah if you're not sick of
rabbit chats
well there's plenty more coming up and i
talk with the rabbit loving one of a
kind amy sedaris
life could be a dream
hello
hello we'll meet again that night that
was crazy hanging out at your house was
one of the most i know we haven't done
it since we got to do it again
and i meant this when i said it it felt
i remember leaving that night and
thinking like oh yeah we should do this
regularly this is such a why not well um
and paul downs i saw him recently and he
said he saw you in l.a i just texted
paul downs oh you did oh yeah he's great
don't you talk to him for this no i
won't oh he would be good he'd be great
yeah he's funny paul and i we've worked
together a bunch and amy paul and i did
a movie called ghost team which you
probably saw
did we see it
i did see it you saw it absolutely i was
talking to the audience but uh oh are we
rolling yes oh yeah ghost team i do
that's where we met no no we went before
then we had met before them but we got
to know each other so we worked together
yeah and and it was a great cat i mean
it really was you and
that's i guess that's where i met paul
downs and john heater who had played
napoleon dynamite and we did a really
fun thing once um where we did john
heater had a really good sense of humor
about napoleon dynamite would you say
yes he did and he yeah and god i can't
believe that was this real dance move in
the movie oh you were blown away by that
yeah i was blown away by it
had such a good
he would bring it up often in fact
like it's like it's kind of like that
scene in plain dynamite yeah and and and
it all culminated when we all did our
impression of
john do you remember that yes i do
that's a really funny video i do um uh
okay so you uh prefer live audiences and
i do and i like the energy of a live
audience and because you can't um you
have one take you have one chance you're
not gonna
you know stop you i mean now they can
edit stuff but they're not gonna you
just get away with more in a way you
feel more like you can be yourself in
the moment more and more immediate
things if something happens you i mean
your appearances on letterman were
always very uh shoot from the hip it
felt that way i mean i was always
prepared but then oh you worked but then
i was always prepared but then i had my
list of things i knew i wanted to get in
there that i didn't want to run by the
producers but then once you're out there
you never know what you know he'll start
off with something then it's just you're
derailed but you have stuff to fall back
on but
yeah i missed doing letterman the ipad
you you he and he had a really good
almost like flirtatious well i was in
the i didn't really later when people
were like oh you too and i was like oh
but when you're in it you don't think
about it that way and then when people
would start saying that would you then
play it up like i i no never uh never it
was just natural it's just natural and
and i think i asked you this before but
you don't keep in touch with him
um he called me like three years ago or
something just to say hey how you doing
it was one of those things i know
kidding no and i was in my underpants
and i was
petting my rabbit
are you the rabbit is how old now tina
yeah tina's healthy four
so but tina's the second rabbit that i
met too the two is my third rabbit but i
found out tina was a male rabbit like a
few months ago i always said i thought
it was a girl named bertina and i just
found out it's a boy i i can't hesitate
to ask this but how did you find out um
they had to insert a catheter she was
sick and they was like amy this is a boy
rabbit not a female it's really hard to
tell sorry i know oh i thought you meant
it was hard to talk about to tell the
story i love it it's like living with a
big raving queen that's the way i look
at it a big big queen
how i would have thought that rabbits
had because hamsters have very prominent
testicles
did you know that rabbits and hamsters
are very different no i didn't know that
i didn't know that yeah hamsters have
really big
i'm surprised no i want one
i'm surprised you didn't know that
tina's your third rabbit since i met you
years ago i i don't know which number
rabbit i met but i know that um it was a
lot beard rabbit no no no never had a
lapierre but wasn't it with um
it was huge who are you with didn't i
meet you with um
sam rockwell what's his friend i can't
believe lilly thorne's husband oh josh
thank you
yeah hamilton that's right i met you
with josh
i think it was your it was an older
apartment too i don't think it's the
appropriate
bleaker yeah christopher right near
where they live now yep yeah well that
was in the lobby that was huge it was a
big no no that was a mini that was a
little rabbit
okay you probably just yeah no that was
maybe i was smaller and i remember
but i remember you having uh do you
still have this you have your wall was
covered with fortune fortunes from
fortune cookies oh that was my i don't
know what possessed me to do it i i no i
went to chinatown got these chinese
candies i emptied the candy save the
wrappers and i used to pay tape and i
put them all over my hallway and then
went over it with packing tape and so it
was like a padding yeah they were
beautiful colors that's the prettiest
candy ever but i had to make four trips
to chinatown in like august
because i was never buying enough
candies and i was like oh my god it
smelled it wreaked and i was like it's
awful right i can't believe i'm in
chinatown whenever all my friends are at
the beach there are
there are bad smells i was just there
yesterday there are smells why um i was
going to brook it was actually a really
nice trip i took my bike uh across the
bridge oh my god i had a little stone on
gay pride yeah i was very proud of
myself wow good for you i was gay proud
of myself
but i i
i was i remember those um i hadn't been
there in a while and especially on a day
like that because it was so oppressively
hot and and you're like
punched in the face by these odors you
know but yeah yeah yeah yeah i like
black world charm
yeah yeah smells yeah but odors that
you're not
bad but not familiar chinatown yeah it
was like fishy kind of you're just
imagining it you think of uteruses yeah
you always hear those stories
yeah yeah yeah drive
dried up pieces of body yeah yeah
salted salted well this is this is going
to be the teaser for this episode dried
speaking of dried up pieces of uteruses
or uteri yeah speaking of which i just
had a tooth pulled oh so i keep smiling
i keep forgetting i don't have and my
brother david was like oh my god i'm
like well i don't want to wear the
flipper it's so nasty i get one
it's a long story i keep losing well
well you're on a podcast
anyway
i keep forgetting so i smile i have a
why did you get it pulled
i i broke it i um yeah i broke it
how they said it was for me grinding my
teeth oh at night yeah and i didn't even
know i was like oh i you know i was
grinding my teeth so so now you have to
wear a mouth guard i don't mind then he
gave it's clear and he goes you can wear
it out i'm like really
i'm gonna wear this out so then they
went back to tennessee because are you
wearing your night light garden i'm like
when i go out
[Laughter]
if i'm getting really dressed i don't
mind wearing the night guard but i just
i'm so pissed yeah to have an extra
thing to do it's just like pulling it
it's so barbaric to get a tooth bolt and
also the needle is very painful i'm
usually a good sport in the chair i
pride myself on being able to take
needles but but that needle that goes in
the roof of your mouth
i made a face i've never made before you
know speaking of chinatown i made a face
i've never made before and then that
needle was so painful tears were coming
out of my eyes i think
they do really gelled yeah but it's not
enough it's really bad and you look at
it you can't help but see it it's
everything's being done right in front
of your face yeah it's really it's
really rough i don't want to ever ha
next time i want to just be put to sleep
if that's possible not permanently just
temporary think about it let me think
about it yeah life is short
well i heard you sam letterman
you're like life isn't sure because i
was endless yeah
yeah did you know that i i heard that
yeah people say life is short i'm like
it doesn't seem short to me it seems
like it's never gonna happen right does
it ever seem sure are there moments
where you think in the good moments like
when you're uh what
when i'm with my family i mean that's
what i'm happiest when i'm around
anybody in my family we're together i'm
always
the happiest you're very close it seems
we just all get along really well and
you can just be yourself in in a way
that's different because they know you
so well well yeah yeah yeah it's like
your brother remember my brother yeah
and you take trips with your brother
right
a lot of vacations he was here the other
day and we went to hudson yards have you
been there yet yeah you have i just went
the other new all the new stuff there or
am i yeah it's it's exciting it's almost
like something you'd see in tokyo
or something you mean that building that
that the whole thing a mall but this but
they would have better stores in tokyo
but but the the tourist trap is what we
called it it's like you see all the
tourists you're like that's the tourist
trap yeah it does look like an actual
trap yeah it does like some like mcs
sure thing i didn't go in that i didn't
either i just looked at it from the mall
well i like watching people tourists
watch things you know i like watching
them uh because now everyone's got
selfies and stuff and right although
i've noticed uh you know thankfully
fewer selfie sticks lately that that
seems to be a trend that didn't you're
right but i did see some sticks and i
thought i haven't seen those in a while
but i wish somebody would write a
etiquette book for new york i was
thinking it'd be such a good idea
because you know i live in the west
village and everyone comes in for the
gay pride and i'm just like you'd want
to be open and be like whatever but i
just cannot understand because they
automatically come with an attitude some
people like because they think we're
going to be rude
their chests are puffed out i'm going to
get yeah they overcome they're like
we're not like that it's just like the
rules just like when you go to
you know europe or tokyo or anywhere
else and you're like okay you walk on
this side you try to assimilate yeah
yeah yeah i'm just get so angry because
it's like in the phone and then you just
sound like an old person but a lot of
it's just consideration i just feel like
there's need to be someone needs to
write that book well we have a friend
who is a fan of the show james duffy who
one who grew up in new york and has
brought this up and wants to write that
book
he has a few rules and now of course you
have to add rules because now everyone's
on their phone so a lot of it too is
like with pedestrian traffic people are
just not aware of one another and that's
the thing that struck christian and i
went to tokyo last summer and i and i
know you go often
and i
fell in love i've been there before but
not for a significant amount of time and
i fell in love with it i fell in love
with the
this the sense of respect that they have
oh it's so considerate and so it's um
civilized because then you come back
here it's like rikers you know you're
just like you we can't even have nice
seats on the train you know there
they're like upholstered and you know
it's so nice and and they respect old
people yes it is like a jungle here i
know i know it's so it's it's such a
dramatic difference when you go and in
fact i went from there to london and
even that was oh sure
a drastic difference big difference but
better accents i mean you know i love
hearing the accidents in london kids
weren't quite as cute though oh yeah
japanese babies there's nothing cuter
nothing's cuter although baby pandas
maybe sure baby bunnies and baby chicks
okay i'll give you bunnies
that's a little jerry do you miss doing
jerry blank that was strange i knew
jerry a lot like you were talking
earlier you slip into it i slip into
jerry all the time we all do uncle bear
will paul will we always think of that's
a jerry thing
definitely say that but the face is like
i was doing that way before jerry oh you
were i go into it
yeah you do yeah do you miss playing
characters like that do you miss uh you
get to do it on at home yeah i play
characters on at home
pretty much that's untrue coming up with
the new characters like patty hogg i
play on the show is kind of a new
character so that that was fun i usually
i just kind of do the same characters
i've been doing since i was five or six
yeah they play around with the same ones
they you know grow a little bit or a
change it here or there but patty was
brand new so that was kind of fun you've
talked about your god's son who who
you're very yes you got some sounds
both paul paul danella's kids um and and
just imagining you playing interacting
with them is so fun i've done some
stupid stuff with them and then when i
do it i come home and i write it down i
have my list
of things like i can't believe i just
did that with them
i played pretty hard with them yeah i
bet i've been latest nothing i mean i
haven't done anything that
i mean
horrible like i used to but uh we played
pretty hard how old are they now how old
are seven and and four oh okay so now
i've got them putting a mattress on the
stairs and flying i mean it's just
stupid like do it head first and then
i'm like oh what am i thinking you know
the seven-year-old is like well i don't
know i could easily hit that one like oh
yeah you're right or you're right don't
tell your dad
i'm always like so he's hit the age of
reason and you're like [ __ ] yeah he's
starting to like
outgrow your antics yes
i've been talking about this lately
because i've been hanging i don't have
kids myself i'm 41 and i but i love kids
and i love interacting with them and and
i wonder if that's why people have kids
to to
kind of
regressed as an excuse to regress back
to that i'm sure stage i have them i
mean i never wanted children but i and
yet you're so good yeah i'm good with
them and it's fun to be boys are fun
yeah you know they always want to do
something or they're just they're just
really great kids and good natured
that's so nice yeah it really is do you
ever think when you're playing with them
at like is there ever a moment where you
you are thinking life is short and
you're thinking god maybe i i yeah i
mean i grow up so if they do if i grow
up so if i ask you they do they grow up
so fast
i'm like oh my god i
can't believe it but i do make a point
to see them a lot they live in new york
they live in new jersey okay so i go to
new jersey a lot and visit and you grew
up with a lot you had a lot of siblings
six kids all together in the family and
would you say you were closest with
david
i think so yeah david and my little
brother growing up but we all still got
along but david's probably the most
because we also got into show business
and we have more common that way and he
is it's funny david's somebody whom i've
never met but i feel like i know him
just because of his writing uh and
you're mentioned a lot in his writing
does he ever
does he ever
hesitate to or voice this to you does he
ever run things by you that he's
sometimes oh yeah or he did he was
writing a story we all went home to see
my dad and um he
he never does this where he just threw
out every he came home and he wrote out
everything that he remembered and sent
to all of us and said is there anything
i left out you know and so he goes
normally he doesn't do that but i'm like
oh yeah i remember this this and this
and then you know i like it when you see
him you know when you're around a writer
just everything they're just constantly
thinking you know you can
tell this is a story processing yeah
does that ever
i don't know i'm guessing the answer is
no but does that ever make you
uncomfortable i never think about it in
the moment you know but he's looking at
it a whole different way isn't that
fascinating yeah but you are a writer i
mean you do write i'm writing on my feet
with improv but i don't i'm not
disciplined i'm not going to sit down
and i'll do a list but i'm not going to
sit down and write something out i mean
i'll beat something out but i'm not like
disciplined like david uh-huh you know
but you have similar you're able to
paint similar pictures um he does it
with words and you do with characters
when
what is it like going on on a vacation
with you guys like you both you spend
christmas time in japan a lot right no
we spend christmas in london a lot and
then on japanuary in january we go to
tokyo of course and then you know san
francisco we'll just pick little places
i want to go to berlin next time he's
there because he loves berlin but i
think i'm working so i can't go you're
working on tr at home yeah we just
started writing the third season oh
that's great yeah and and you writers
that you've worked with before on stream
yep uh um well col cola school is
writing this season he wrote last season
too i don't know if you know cole he's
really funny he's a great guy oh wait
wait he plays chassis on the show okay
okay yeah he's really funny oh yeah yeah
it's such a great show it's um so season
three you're doing that's uh that's okay
i have to look at my notes yeah season
three and then also this guy jeremy
behler b-e-i-l-e-r baylor beeler he's
really uh somebody i didn't know and uh
he's hilarious jeremy that's he's new
he's new um i'm just i'm crazy about him
uh
and peter gross do you know peter groves
i don't know okay he's really funny too
yeah i know the name and paul's been on
paul downs who we've mentioned i think
we can mention maybe a dozen yeah he was
on the second season um i read uh when
you were a teenager you used to work at
winn dixie yes first job and that's you
that was your first challenge my first
job was one day that's in north carolina
you said you were born in new york i was
born in oh upstate new york like but i
moved to the south when i was three okay
so i was raised i was raised in north
carolina what are what are your top ten
favorite memories from upstate new york
and i'm kidding
uh you so but when dick when dixie and
you used to i can imagine there must be
so many of these stories you'd make fake
announcements over this yes and then
they took the microphone away from me oh
belinda the head cashier
oh my god we did not get along belinda
and i and then mr blueberry who was my
manager i swear to god
this was real his name was mr blueberry
you can't come on no you can't make that
out yeah you can't i mean you could but
i love working in a grocery store i like
to see everyone's combinations what
they're gonna make i'd like to see the
people who would come in
two minutes before we closed by ice
cream
you know those people and i just loved
everything about working in a grocery
store and then i stopped working in it
because we got scanners
and i liked the old and i didn't i just
didn't want to i didn't want to work on
the scanners you used to input it
manually yeah yeah you know you just and
i was always in the longest line because
i would give out the extra coupons you
know that you can get a fat daddy with
um
yeah and but i like uniform jobs and i
stole my uniform from there oh you must
because
you wear uniforms often on the show
what was mr blueberry like
um he had sandy hair big blue eyes he
was having an affair with somebody who
was working i didn't remember her name
um and it was big thing that he was
having an affair with this person he was
the manager um he was the manager and we
got along i really liked him and then i
had another younger manager named jeff i
think it was jeff kelly and he had a
boat
what was and belinda was kind of
aggressive
she i think she had a crush on mr
blueberry oh she just had a thing with
women and she would always get on me for
not having polished shoes like the white
shoes a little dirty
old uh middle-aged woman yeah um yeah
and she would make she'd come bring mr
blueberry peaches and cream like a big
bowl of cream with chopped up
peaches in it like swishing out like
what are you doing like
bringing that to him at nine o'clock
maybe that maybe that was like she had
an aphrodisiac
she just had a nice southern accent you
know
i egged your car one night because she
was so mean to me so i egged her car
what kind of what
can we do um
belinda bringing mr blueberry uh peaches
she just would bring it me get i brought
you some peaches and cream oh well thank
you belinda uh that that's fine you can
set it around you go up there and you
know their office a little higher up and
so they could see everything and
yeah but i really i didn't and then i
worked at another grocery store in
chicago for a while this is when you so
you moved to chicago after north
carolina
was your intention to be in second city
david went to school art institute in
chicago and he said there's a place here
called second city it's perfect for you
you should come here so i went and took
some classes
and then i loved it so then i ended up
moving to chicago oh wow so you were
you were that close that even at that as
a teenager if you you wanted to be
around him you wanted to always i
emulated david i mean he did characters
and oh yeah i mean yeah he's the one who
got me into
all this stuff wow wow
um
can do you remember any of those sorry
to dwell on these fake announcements i
just i don't remember and you know the
um inconvenient funds on you know
terminal three
um uh something spilling in an aisle you
know just stupid stuff like that yeah
someone said welfare which i you know
wouldn't do now like
you know because we took welfare
whatever you call it example food stamps
yeah um yeah i i somebody was talking
one of somebody i interviewed i think
was jeremy renner said we were talking
about five that stage when you're five
and six years old and the and the joy of
being an actor and we were
unpacking where that comes from and
where that sense of joy comes from and
and i i wonder if it's because we get to
be kids i mean it's as simple as we get
to experience you mean playing with them
yeah or or being an actor at all i mean
for me it's more like i can i can ask my
god son john carlo questions i should
know the answer to and i know he's not
judging me yes but how many states are
there giancarlo yeah i know the answer
to that but there's a lot of questions
i'm like oh he's i can ask him anything
i want and not be ashamed that i i don't
know the answer to it so that's what i
like is i can have a real conversation
with someone who's not judging you he's
not judging there's something really
pure yeah
like batteries like i didn't know you
know i know the plus and minus but i
think you know he just teaches me stuff
i should know oh that's interesting yeah
he junk they're pretty funny because
paul's funny and they're getting you
know they have a good sense of humor
this is paul dinello who um along with
stephen colbert the three of you started
you started a comedy troupe together it
was how we did exit d7 and
strangers exit 57 was was that right
after second city
yeah that was after second city i would
come here to new york to do plays with
david and we were doing a play and then
they uh hbo downtown it offered us a
sketch show not you know some of the
people in the play so
um that's how i got into tv oh david was
oh you were acting in the play david was
writing the plays well we worked on him
together and then i was i was in him uh
oh oh oh um and
did you ever harbor when when you were
doing this did you ever want to be on
snl was that ever an ambition i had a
meeting with lauren michaels when i was
doing one of the plays he was looking
for someone to replace jenny groffalo
and so we just had a meeting i think he
was feeling me out and you know it's one
of those things like i'm doing exactly
what i've always wanted to do i'm
working with david in new york city
doing plays or sold out little house and
i couldn't imagine doing i think if i if
he had offered me something like five
years before we had that meeting i would
have jumped on it but it was kind of
like too late almost but i don't know
that he didn't flatter it off for me the
job but i mean i think he was feeling me
out it was there it was like on on the
table or near the table yeah we were
just
you know what are you doing i was like
i'm so happy doing what i'm doing it's
just too late to me so you weren't in
any way intimidated by that by his
presence or his company because i was
doing what i love doing so i didn't want
anything from him i didn't try we were
just having a little conversation oh he
had a cold oh really
[Music]
how do you remember those i just
remember he was sick
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
what was the process like writing with
david
we would get high and they would laugh
really hard and just
write it all you know take notes and
then he would write something he would
never write high david never wrote hi
and then he the next day you know he
would write something out in the morning
then i'd come meet him and we'd read it
and then we'd laugh and come up with
more stuff i mean no it was the best
just imagine because our minds worked
really well together that way hmm did
you miss that why do you don't i do i
miss it with him yeah do you ever talk
about doing that again
i don't know now that he has his books
and i do this we just kind of did the
eight plays and i don't know if we'll
ever do one again who knows like when
you're on vacation together like when
you're traveling around together
i'm sure there are moments where your
some creative spark is ignited and sure
but we never say let's do yeah yeah i
don't know if we will or not we'll see
did jerry just come when you then went
on to do strange with candy with those
guys
we talked about her a little bit but but
was jerry somebody that she was just
somebody you were always doing she was
just kind of like jerry and all the
plays i did with david i would just give
her it was the same face
but i would give her a different look
and different background but she because
i always wanted to do the kind of
actress where you know they do all these
different roles but they always look the
same yeah like ryan's not gonna really
that's true i mean she can talk all she
wants to about this being a different
character but you're still trying to
hang on and not even her name popped in
my head but you know you're still
hanging on to your looks and you want to
be the same but you're not i'm supposed
to be convinced that you know you're
this different person so i wanted to
always have a character like that where
you can't change that face it's like
come on you really and so when we did
strangers i just we just changed her
background paul found that old video of
flory fisher so junkie [ __ ] so we used
her background and colbert had the idea
that i would learn the wrong lesson and
then i had the idea that we would do
after school specials so we all kind of
brought something to the table and um
was there always did you always have a
fascination with movies things
shows like after school specials that
were so kind of um
sanitized no i loved them i mean we just
made fun of them didn't you it's the
same with movie of the week so just or
sometimes when a movie comes out you're
like oh that would have been a perfect
movie of the week yeah you didn't need
to do a big release and charge people
money yeah it would have been good for
tv it's totally that happens a lot well
that's why i love the christian i love
hallmark movies oh the best yeah chris
around christmas time
if you're listening to this and you have
not yet experienced hallmark christmas
movies yeah well i've always wanted yeah
me too you know and just do it really
straight but then when i get really good
acting like anne haiti is in them a lot
and you're just like yeah you just make
it so much better when they're really
good actors and you're not as good it's
well they're still good they bring
something else to it and it's but the
story's always lame so they they're just
better than them there's always a baking
contest and there's always they always
have to save some old thing you know
like if it was the old
church house or or if it was somebody's
uh something that had been in the family
for a long time right and and there was
always an uh a love that had been
unrequited like somebody left when they
were 18 or 19. and there's no and there
are no stakes right it's like why
wouldn't you just be together you're
handsome she's pretty you get along and
they're like
oh i love them so much i love it they're
great we watch them all the time um you
have been doing
such a how do you pick the things you do
you do bojack horseman and kimmy schmidt
are they things that just kind of
pop up or do you they popped up they
both were offered to me oh things like
that yeah and it was bojack's been great
to work on i think we have two or three
more episodes to do of that but i love
doing that show
um
and then um
and then kimmy schmidt's fun too
is there something that you and and at
home with amy there's something that
obviously just came from you this was
something that you had been
what was the genesis for that what i've
been wanting to do a cooking show i mean
dave and i used to do a fake one growing
up a lot and um i just
always had it in my head that i was
going to do it was based on this local
show that we had in north carolina at
home with peggy mann and i just remember
it was really boring and um and i just
remember pointing the tv saying oh i'm
gonna do that show when i'm older it was
kind of like plain house this woman in
her house yeah um so i love that stuff
and then i did a cookbook and a craft
book because i kept putting it off and
putting it off because i was it was
almost like it just it took 18 years to
do because i was like a fine stew you
know soup so it's kind of just happened
when it happened you just have to wait
for the right time and and you're a
cupcake company oh yeah yeah well dusty
food cupcakes yeah oh it was illegal
yeah i mean i sold them out of my
my apartment cupcakes and cheese balls
yeah
what who would you sell them to just
friends i would take them to joe's
coffee
say you can't
you know i don't know how many i'm gonna
bring you and you can't uh you know um
cash only under the table no requests
you know i had all these rules but they
were like fine so sometimes i just bring
them seven
but but then cupcakes became pretty
popular and i didn't want to play
anymore oh this was before that before
like magnolia became magnolia was just
kind of happening at the same time so we
both and i just wanted to sell them for
a dollar i wasn't out to make any big
profit i just wanted something to sell i
like allowance money i always like to
sell something me too when i was a kid
oh i used to have a little stand at the
end of our driveway and i would sell i
used to make little animal noses and oh
wow
i once found all these frog eggs and i
hatched them i sold them as tadpoles
separately oh my god yeah a dollar a
tadpole how did you get the scar on your
forehead that's a good question uh
speaking of tadpoles
i was too it's not a good story i wish i
had a better story for but i was like
two years old i was jumping on my bed
and i slipped and i fell and i i cracked
it open but i remember my brother my
older brother was watching the electric
company and he loved it so much zoom
zoom zoom zoom or that zoom
wait i don't remember that i was zoomed
in electric company i liked uh three two
one i remember three two one contact at
the end that was my favorite part uh but
he didn't want to get up and and and i
guess maybe i i was two so i was
probably always crying and i but i was
screaming bloody murder and uh he didn't
come up in time oh man and so i guess it
was a pretty bad guy
they said they put me in a straight
jacket no yeah they put me together she
wouldn't mess with it yeah cause i they
it was i was too young to get uh
anesthetic i think local honest
anesthesia so i they didn't want me to
kind of fuss with it as they were
working on it and i have
speaking of memory i like glimpses of
that i have like i can smell i have
moments of it but otherwise my memory
from back then is almost non-existent i
remember seeing empire strikes back when
i was a kid i remember flashes of like
touching frogs and stuff things that i
loved right but but so i'm jealous of
people like you and your brother who
have like really strong recall well
david i remember and he forgot about
this my sister tiffany took an ibm
pencil and stabbed him in the eye with
it we were fighting over we wanted to
watch i love lucy or the flintstones
and uh uh and david was like i forgot
about that i'm like you're kidding me
so she stabbed him yeah in the eyeball
and we all had to go to the eye doctor
that's really weird i stabbed him in the
eye right underneath the eye with a
pencil do you still have a mark that
scares me yeah he still has a mark from
a pencil
um
how would you decide who what to watch i
mean there's six of you there's seven i
know that's why we got a big fight and
you know i didn't care what we were
watching i liked them both
were you like that were you the
peacemaker would you say were you
probably yeah the middle child uh-huh i
always want everyone to get along yeah
yeah you are you like that with your
friends still
i mean i guess i can be that way
you have cool friends yeah you have
really i like your friends when you come
from a large family they're your friends
and then you have other friends but i
don't have a lot of friends i know a lot
of people yeah but i'm not that close
just because i have my family so i think
that's that's something with big
families i'm
similar i think but there are although
there are a few would you say so
and paul dunnell and steven those guys
were just those were more work um paul
you and paul dated for a while we did it
for eight years but paul and i are still
best friends you're very cool yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're super close it's like
did you watch the fosse vernon show yes
they reminded me a lot of me invited me
a lot of me and david and then it
reminded me a lot of me and paul
because you know you've got those unless
you know paul being married and you got
those triangle relationships where it's
it's interesting it's like well we're
work partners but then you have a wife
and kids but then i keep getting you
know down you know falling down the hole
a little bit but i that reminded me so
much i love that i i thought rockwell
and michelle williams were amazing
everybody in it was amazing yeah i loved
it god did would you want to do
something dramatic like that i think i'm
a phony i don't think you i don't think
you'd buy it i mean i think i love
watching people who can act that way and
they're really good at it i just don't
think that's the strength of mine and
being like no you shouldn't like i don't
have a desire to try to cry
and it's just not my what i'm interested
in yeah your friends
do you ever
have you you're friends with justin
thoreau and sarah jessica parker have
you worked with these people do you
prefer not working with with friends do
you think it's
i like working with friends yeah one of
my favorite episodes last season
with uh justin thoreau i got a little
take on the ghost of mrs muir i mean
he's justin's so funny and he can do
drama yeah and you know he's yeah he's a
good friend i've known him for i was
thinking 19 years i've known him oh my
god yeah around the time
you knew so you met him through phil i
met him through phil hoffman yeah and
then we clicked immediately me and
justin how'd you meet phil
um i waited on him at marion's
and i think i reached out to him and we
just became oh really friends yeah when
you were waiting tables at marion's oh
okay i waited on him and justin oh no
kidding yeah and they must have just
thought you were
a hoot
i don't really remember it till later
but i think i approached i reached out
to phil we were neighbors oh and we had
mutual friends
um
so you had a lot of different jobs when
you were in when you first moved to new
york i worked at marion's i worked at
gourmet garage
and i worked at mary's fish camp what's
mary's fish camp it's a fish restaurant
on fourth it's um yeah is it still there
it's still there oh wow yeah fourth in
like charles did you ever go by and and
say hey remember no
i loved working there but then it became
like i was working on there when i was
working there when i was working and
thinking strangers with candy and it was
just kind of like
i just loved waitressing and i missed
it's fun to waitress when you don't have
to waitress because you can play
waitress
again the cash i like making money but
then it became other people would come
by and i just kind of felt like i was
taking money from waiters who needed it
yeah and i
just it just seemed like a bit and it
wasn't a bit but that's just kind of how
it started to feel like and so i just
thought it would be better not to do it
anymore you like those so so
with the things you it's sort of like
working out win dixie's get kind of the
appeal of working at a you and you
actually enjoyed that job yeah i like
working with the public i like i like
hearing arguments i like hearing them
ask about cockles and just i like to see
who tips and who doesn't and who's drunk
and who isn't i love that just that if
i'd like to see the manager please i
just it's my favorite line ever
likes the manager please and you just
know what's behind that you just so here
we go do you like ordering takeouts do
you like talking to the people on the
phone i don't like doing it i don't
order in that much but i do talk on the
phone i don't use any apps like that
yeah i i miss that the times i use an
app to get food i miss
calling up and going through the process
i miss interacting with you but you can
still do it yeah i know i do yeah
they're always so shocked when you call
it seems
yeah and i'm like oh i guess people do
it online now i don't know yeah when you
hang out with your godsons um are there
or are there kids in your life do you
ever like see kids and think
oh i'm so glad i don't have to deal with
this oh my god all the time yeah
aren't you don't you yeah i mean yeah
yeah absolutely
yeah and then there are those moments
where i mean
lately they've been
fewer and further between where i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's fun but then you get you
know but i always have fun hanging out
with my kids i'm always like i'm gonna
go out there all day and i love it yeah
and plus you know the parents love it
too because they know you're gonna be
playing with their kids totally they can
go they scramble the minute you arrive
they're off doing something
each of them
so it's just it's a good thing to do for
your friends it's totally like i'm gonna
come by for the afternoon and you know
it's mutually beneficial yeah um but you
must have a lot of nieces and nephews we
don't have one niece what i know out of
all the kids we have one niece
and she's fun her name's madeline she's
she's really great madeline's a great
name yeah i know i'm that's surprising
isn't it i know
all those kids i know only two got
married in my family lisa my oldest and
and my little brother paul oh wow did
did you grow up with religion was was
that part of the orthodox church oh
that's right yes
and and were your parents quite pious
they were we went to church just because
you know they didn't ever come in with
us really they just dumped us off at
church but
um it was and it was in greek so none of
us ever knew what they were saying but i
think that's where visually we got you
know the crying grandmothers and the
blood red carpet and the icons and the
weeping
incense it's very graphic ceremony so i
think we're all that's what we took from
the church and that's fine then we could
just make up what he's saying and yeah
guilt-free yeah
you can make it fun yeah yeah we made it
fun so uh and i still sometimes i'll go
back to the greek orthodox church with
my dad and it's funny the same people
are there really
back in north carolina yeah north
carolina no they're still there they're
still some of the greeks when you go to
the greek church you're like oh my god
look who's here yeah yeah you can't even
believe it
you're a little
yeah right oh wow it's funny that they
would drop you off there and not go
themselves my mom would
afterwards do stuff with us but now my
then my dad as he got older he went to
church by himself it's just
just so boring no no yeah of course
church is so boring but i always think
like i got yeah for you you must have
gotten so oh my god it was crazy but i
love the idea of community and church
and i always think why can't we just buy
a church in the middle of manhattan and
then we can invite our friends and be
like justin long's gonna give a service
on you know on uh on uh i don't know on
what on uh give us how not to do a
podcast yeah i need to do a podcast on
how to give people the right uh address
or friendship or you know it's just a
place you know you just get together
with people that you like it would be so
much fun so fun yeah and i know that's
the thing that there is so much of that
that is appealing you know the commute
the sense of community gathering and
even having a ritual i like the idea of
rituals me too yeah you celebrate
people's birthdays oh you must love
birthdays i mean i i know p i remember
people's birthdays yeah we celebrated
them big in my family really yeah i
always write it down on my calendar and
then i'm like oh today's esther's
birthday and then yeah i usually
dorman i'm like oh when's your birthday
and then i write it down
never i never forget that's nice yeah
i'm obsessed with like trying to
remember someone's birthday oh it just
sticks in my head and then i go home
right now what is a typical day with you
and david on a on a trip like when
you're going to berlin david shot we
shop david walks a lot too it's like
nothing like when you're with david you
know you're going to walk like oh you
only did 22 miles today and you're just
like oh my god but um we have we're good
companions of our shopping goes we go
into stores and it's also close shopping
yeah clothes shopping what he likes is
like you're still interacting with
people and sales people and
you know um and that's so that's part of
it he can use his japanese oh he speaks
he speaks japanese and then we'll leave
a storm like why are they doubled over
laughing he's like just asked if they
had a bathroom like david
you said something you know they're in
there laughing really hard um so it's
just he
you know but that's mostly what we do if
we go to a museum we go to the museum
gift shop oh really that's great
socially you strike me as somebody who
is
almost totally fearless but what what
fears do you have and what fears do
besides that that means driving yes it
gives me a lot of fear yeah you know
what i mean that's that's scary to me
yeah trying to think the last time i was
really scared
like i always think it'd be scary to be
sleepy and then you have to go up and go
to the bathroom and you bump into
somebody what if somebody was in your
apartment well thanks i didn't have that
one until now or you know i have that's
a new one about the apartment above me
because i didn't it was for sale and i
didn't want anyone i didn't want to hear
anyone above me you know so i just
bought it and that's what we write the
show you know i use it as an office but
my friend adam was like what if you hear
someone walking up there
i'm like oh my god why'd you say that oh
like no i'm good
yeah
that is scary it is what about ghosts
i i mean i i don't know if i'm afraid of
a ghost
i mean i've had some experiences where i
felt like a presence of a girl yeah you
said that you know before but i don't
know if uh yeah i don't know i love
hearing people's goals
and i could listen to him all the time
dave is not so crazy about him david
hates hearing a ghost story why i guess
he just doesn't believe in it or
whatever but i've had some a couple
things where i'm like i was definitely a
ghost i love ghost stories because
because the idea is
i don't i i want to believe there
is something there it it gives me hope
that it's not just this not that this is
fast but even if it was this then i was
sure we wouldn't know either way so if
you have lived a million lives totally
you've been around so many times you
don't know it that's what we could be
ghosts we don't know
right can we be
uh yeah i'm a ghost remember yeah i
don't know
yeah what were they can you tell me one
of the experiences i was in bed it was
after my sister died and i felt a really
hard pinch on my toe enough to wake me
up and then i heard like a flutter
it sounded like a flutter of bats
leaving my bedroom but i remember
laughing about it like it was a it was a
hard
pinch but it was a you know humorous
pinch too you know what i mean like a
playful one yeah playful one but it was
hard and then i heard that sound i was
very aware i was very like okay this is
real and right away you felt you you
assigned your sister to totally i mean
that's true yeah that's who i
saw on my head wow
and that doesn't that to you was hum you
found the humor in it yeah was she was a
very playful person
i mean she could be yeah she could be
huh it is it's you know horrible losing
a brother you expect your parents to go
you it was still bad enough awful losing
a parent but you don't expect a brother
and sister to go before a parent so it's
pretty shocking but uh yeah it's it's
terrible how long ago was it tiffany
like i think maybe five years now
four or five years now good and she had
no kids no kids
oh [ __ ] yeah no i can't imagine i i
don't know
i i
i often do this with with
tragic things i try to imagine there's
things that i try to if only to have
empathy for the people who are going
through those things i know
but
yeah yeah
again
i'm always like i want to go first i'd
rather yeah i'm like please please let
me go i cannot
handle it my brother my family and i'm
family members i i [ __ ] i don't can't
imagine i'm sorry uh
uh okay let's let's switch gears here
do you ever use jerry blank to kind of
like pivot and it's like a fun joke sure
i mean it's easy yeah it is okay you
guys i've noticed you doing it
life could be a dream
um i'm gonna just ask you some quick
questions if you don't yes sir
female aries
uh five feet i don't know how much i
weigh hiv negative
should i be negative
i think
fingers crossed fingers crossed um what
what is your do you text you text i like
to text yeah what's your most commonly
used emoji i don't use emojis a lot but
i do like the one with a little leaf
which one's that i don't know it's a
leaf it's a little green thing and it
makes me just happy because it's a
pretty shade of green and when i see it
and um
and so that's the one i like seeing but
i don't i don't use a mushroom sometimes
okay mushrooms make me laugh but they're
too cute you're like you're like that's
a cute mushroom i want an ugly mushroom
uh what animals make you laugh what
animals do you really care about besides
rabbits you know you love rabbits make
you laugh yeah yeah squirrels my whole
family's into squirrels squirrels come
on yeah they're the best and chipmunks
are a doorbell i was just thinking about
letterman uh i was recounting this an
appearance of yours and he and the way
he announced you he said well he went on
about how funny and lovely you were but
then he said
and this is letterman he goes
but you should know she's a bit off oh
she's a [ __ ] she's a bit of a loose
wire or something something like that
and then you came out in this crazy huge
puffy
like oh right now i went up yeah that
was funny right it was so funny
but i thought to myself like what must
that be like to
have the bar raised like that or what or
to have those expectations put on you
well a lot of times
last minute because someone fell out so
what i might i love last minute because
it's like well i couldn't prepare so
much i always had a letterman thing on
my computer and a notebook things that i
write it down be like oh i gotta
remember that you know so i always felt
like i would be prepared i always had a
dress hanging up so if he called me last
minute it's kind of that good feelings
like but if you push yourself wants to
prepare
better be then it's different if you
could be a professional athlete you ever
think about that what sport would you
play um
i read a lot about athletes
i do i like books about athletes uh
athletes a lot um
uh
but i i if i could be an athlete i mean
i guess a swimmer
maybe i would swim a lot when i was
younger i ran track and fields but i'm
okay not ever having to be an athlete
that's okay do you watch sports ever no
oh really no
the justin throw never drags you to a
game or anything or are you friends who
huh no i don't watch any sports
i mean during the olympics it's
different you know it's fun to watch a
gymnast and all that uh-huh and to hear
the announcements when you're high oh
yeah oh my god i can do that
yeah
oh really she's funny
that's true so easy i'm gonna work out
tomorrow
yeah well there are certain things that
i even not high i think i can do like
sometimes i look at luge and i'm like
and i'm to all the lugias that listen
are going to be very upset to hear that
they're like [ __ ] you but i think i
could go in one of those things it's
like being in a sled oh my god yo
straighten your body yeah if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what is your goat popcorn oh yeah i
love popcorn sweet really bad for your
teeth no i like it plain no salt nothing
boring oh really i'm surprised
somebody's because you're so into sweet
you still aren't into sweets no not so
much anymore when i was little my best
friend's dad was a candy distributor so
she would load up my lunch box every day
it was a dream i'll never forget that
closet as long as i live it was
wall-to-wall candy oh my god can you
imagine no
no
at your friend's house yeah and he
probably wanted to get rid of it he was
probably like take whatever you want
yeah she let me take whatever i wanted i
felt my lunch box yes
what's your thing now to eat what's your
guilty question popcorn oh my guilty
pleasure well popcorn is is my favorite
snack food do i have a guilty pleasure i
was always a funny thing i never feel
guilty about anything like oh yeah huh
i don't have any guilty pleasures as far
as snacks go
bring it on oh yeah yeah
yeah but like when you're you're still
you're craving do you get like
ravenously hungry when you're when
you're stoned i have before sure and
popcorn is the thing that you would go
to yeah i usually have it in my house
but you can get real creative when you
are hungry and be like what have i got
oh yeah but i always have lettuce
because of tina you know my rabbit but
you never really want to make a salad
or
lettuce sandwich yeah um right
yeah i know it's just not satisfying
it's not the same thing that's what i
mean what satisfies that because there
is something about being stone where
it's like well i have been upstairs
because we write the show there's a
snack drawer and i have gone upstairs
and raided the stack drawer
but you don't write the show stone you
just like you do with dave you don't
write it down you come up with idea
stones yeah yeah yeah yeah um
and then we'll use those the next day or
sometimes if they hold up yeah isn't it
funny when it's like at the time you
think it's the best it's like oh that
happens
uh what's your favorite movie of all
time
uh elephant man was my favorite movie
and babe
oh really
i liked babe and a big life-changing
movies i have a list like i remember
when purple rain came out
or the deer hunter came out those are
big life-changing movies
but you're like wow that's really good
boogie nights it's making me look at
things in a different way just you're
like wow that's really yeah you just
remember it i remember i remember
watching the thin red line it was during
a time oh sure oh god those movies where
you feel like
you've been in some sort of
like traumatic like car accident yeah
yeah
yeah you're just like whoa yeah was
there something that made you did you
ever think uh that made was there ever a
movie or a thing that you can point to
that
that that really made you want to be an
actor
or a performer it was more tv like carol
burnett and jonathan winters and ernie
kovacs
you know it was more like
that's what i wanted you know i love the
the set design you know sctv oh yeah you
know the more it was more like that not
not a movie were you ever
insecure about the not you're very
pretty but about the way you look
she's showing me
toothless
but do you struggle with somebody who
never had that kind of
i always played ugly people because it
was fun for me i liked making faces i
like looking ugly because then you take
it all off and you always remember oh
but you're so pretty and i heard that so
much because it's like you looked ugly
for so long and then everyone's like
what are you going to do when you're
older i'm like then and then i'll play
teenagers well you'll look like the
waves
right yeah because jerry blank was 46
you played her when you were 36 yeah
something like yeah was was there older
yeah
but specifically with cherry was there a
reason why you did that why not just
have her it would have been it's just
the way it turned out i just like
playing older
ways huh i didn't really know what to
play my own age or you know someone says
oh be yourself you're like i don't know
right because like when you're a kid
playing when you're playing make-believe
and stuff like rarely are you playing
another kid right you're playing like a
a cowboy or a prince or whatever you
know
it's play it's play it's play it's play
um which is what makes it fun yeah
it's so funny to talk about fun like
that i know it is fun
uh if you could
if you could have dinner with three
people
dead or alive whom you've never met what
would you serve i would serve shell
steaks because i would judge everybody
on how they would want it cooked
oh yeah yeah oh it'd be a good way to
determine yeah what type of person they
are yeah oh you want it well done oh you
want that rare oh you're happy with the
way it is yeah okay the way it is yeah
um whatever's easiest for me
okay
what's um
are there people that you you from the
past or people even now who you admire
who you'd really love to just like
hang out with smoke a joint with
i'm thinking the first person that put
in my head was robert altman only
because i was hanging out with him once
and he was getting high and i remember
him off he didn't offer me any pot he
didn't offer it to me but um i i just
like the fact that he felt that he could
just like you know light it up and if
you want some you know yeah that's cool
um
he didn't offer hanging out with
i mean i guess you know i i i don't have
that list but i'm always happy when i ha
with anybody any yeah that's interesting
yeah um
your favorite muppet who's your favorite
muppet oh i don't know the merlin i i've
seen pictures i don't know
you weren't into the muppets um
no not really what were your things as a
kid what what did you consider shows
like electric oh that's right zoom and
um all mr rogers we watched and uh
missed captain kangaroo
have you seen the mr rogers documentary
yeah i loved it yeah it was really good
there's also a great guild of radnor
documentary if you haven't seen um
that's right i did know that but i
haven't seen it yet that'd be great to
see that's great she said something
really interesting about because she she
was a fat kid even that word i i
hesitate now using that word
fact can you not say fat
i don't know
heavy
then lizzy i don't know wait i don't
know
but then lizzy um i don't know do you
ever get in are you afraid of getting in
trouble for saying the wrong thing
i'm not afraid
yeah i mean this can happen yeah
well maybe not hasn't it's like a fence
and
then your feelings are hurt sorry i mean
i don't care but it hasn't happened yet
i mean
it's pretty remarkable with all things
considered maybe this maybe it'll happen
on this oh bad i don't know yeah maybe
fingers crossed
geez
uh if you could have one superpower what
would it be oh my god a super power i
would love to move something from across
the room to the other like a spoon or
just
you know like this and all of a sudden
my apartment's clean because i don't
have a housekeeper and i do my the
cleaning it's just it's just a chore i
was talking to justin about this the
other day just throw it like it's so
much you know when you talk to some
people and they're like oh i'm so
exhausted and tired i'm like what'd you
do today and they're like well i had to
return some phone calls and i went to
the bank and you're like right and
you're they're worn out and you're like
lazy people say that because they don't
do anything and then sometimes when i
think i'm so lazy and then i make a list
of everything that i did that day and
i'm like
but it's mature day anyway clean your
apartment and you're going to the
grocery store and it's just it's a lot
to to run your life why don't you get
this may sound like a very privileged
because i have too much crap in my
apartment i always think that incense
dust that i've been ash that i've been
saving for 10 years is gonna they're
gonna throw it out you know what i mean
i'm confused yeah they'll probably
assume a lot of the things are to be
trashed exactly a lot it's tricky in my
apartment and there's a lot of it so you
have tons of tchotchkes and i don't like
things to be moved like if it lives
someplace it's gotta live there i'm not
big i will notice if it's moved
as messy as much stuff in my apartment
but i'll see you and tina's running
around and i always think they're going
to step on them you know so well it does
tina i remember that smell of rabbits
christian and i had rabbits growing up
no no what my tina doesn't smell rabbits
don't smell that's because you're not we
didn't take good care of it it was pee
yeah yeah urine skull on their ass no
they're very clean they are they're
constantly grooming themselves yeah
they're good the problem with it now i
didn't mean to suggest good doctors for
rabbits and so i always think i'm going
to have a rabbit the rest of my life but
they keep moving and it's really hard to
find a good rabbit doctor in new york is
that an emergency you know if you need
an operation or something well maybe one
is listening and uh he wants to write
the best one is that catnip and carrots
and uh but it takes me a while to get
there but that's the best the best oh
catnip and carrots that's one of our
sponsors perfect
um what what uh it's just funny you're
right we didn't take good care of the
rabbits now and now i'm remembering the
oh the odor yeah everybody always
follows it we had rabbits and then they
follow it with this horrible and i'm
like i don't hear it that pungent i
remember that smell
it really was because you weren't
changing the hay hey
yeah that's fattening yeah wait i'm one
of those people i'm a snob when it comes
to rabbits oh that's right i'm a rabbit
snap and i got caught stealing carrot
tops
a month ago carrot tops what for tina
because sometimes if they're not loose
some people will take the carrot tops
off the carrots and they discard them i
take them put them in a bag and they're
free sometimes if i don't see any
discarded then i'll snap them off and
take them because people are gonna take
them off anyway and i got caught and
she's like you can't do that i'm like
really excited why why would they be
upset with that they were at like a
farmer's market it was a lifetime my
sixth avenue so i don't do that anymore
i go to the farmer's market and just get
them from there yeah
if you could be one age for the rest of
your life physically oh what would it be
oh physically yes
well 27 28 is the best ever right they
say that's when your body is oh really
yeah
i always feel like i'm 58 now and i
always think like i just soon just
rather be 70 or you know if i'm gonna
live that long just i'm gonna cut to
what these 58 59 yeah but when peop
people in their 60s always say you don't
want that because things start falling
apart
so i don't like
wish that more yeah my 40s were great i
mean i always figured i was 10 years
behind i always looked 10 years younger
i always acted 10 years younger so even
when i was 10 i was two you were small
when you were a kid um
i was small yeah
if you could be an animal what kind of
animal i mean you talking about rabbits
you'd be a rabbit a snake because i'd
move by vibration by vibrations um i
kind of kind of like reincarnated if if
you were to be reincarnated well i'm
gonna i don't know i mean i mean into
rabbits yeah a frog
um i don't know a kangaroo because i'll
have a miracle pocket what other people
i don't know
you keep all your thing your chat in
there what other animals would you want
as a pet um other than a rabbit kittens
are fun um i think rabbits i like a
rabbit because i like taking a prey
animal and making it you know chill out
and relax and knowing that it's safe
move it on up the food chain yeah it's
kind of fun to
look they're always afraid they're going
to be eaten yesterday so i'd like to
take that and be like you're not going
to be eaten uh do you prefer camping or
glamping i think i'd what what is
glamping it's like when you when you
camp but with like kind of fancy people
out at the beach hamptons and they play
country yeah i guess so or like you go
and you have your own you have somebody
set up a fancy uh yurt or something
instead of just going in a pop-up tent
um i camped a lot in girl scouts and i
and i i don't i would i don't care about
camping anymore i don't really i i i
think it's terrifying to me woods alone
are terrifying to me now i mean we grew
up in the woods i know an extra ravine
yeah
people who have a house in the country
with a glass door i'm like oh my god it
just freaks me out oh really so you
don't visit friends out in the country
you don't you don't have trouble
visiting them is one thing but i just
don't think i could live like i lived in
north carolina anymore i like living in
an apartment with people around me i
know my neighbors i like you know uh-huh
so you've gone through either
i'm sorry i asked no i mean if it's
screened in porch if that's no i no
latrines i forget a wolf spiders oh yeah
i don't like spiders people getting on
the appalachian trail i remember the
school people getting these girls went
camping and they got
ra attacked and raped and it was a big
when you're in eighth grade you're like
oh my god and that always stayed with me
like mountain i just never forget oh gee
so before then were you more open to
because you like you said you grew up in
the country you grew up in northeast and
a lot of stories that david writes about
talk he talks about playing in the woods
yeah yeah it was great playing we were
always outside but now that just makes
it's scary to me snakes snakes you don't
like no dogs or cats if you had to have
one
uh cats okay uh beetle stones
beetles or stones yeah a stone they're
rolling stones oh
beaters beetles or rolling stones yeah
i'm sorry i switched gears in a weird
way i went from like insects
[Applause]
um oh gosh
i'm not fun this way oh no the monkeys
okay
i know how bad i am i was like oh i see
what you're saying and i love them but i
like people who like the who
somebody like the who more i like the
rolling stones i i like that person
i never i wouldn't i didn't go down the
beetle road or the world only my sister
i mean we listened to a lot in the house
but more than monkey you have i was into
the monkeys spring or fall do you prefer
fall yeah or fall in new york yeah fall
it reminds me of like to kill a
mockingbird and the wizard of oz when
that would come on and i mean i just
love everything about the fall yeah
everything yeah things dying
yeah
but i like the spring too spring's great
that's great yeah
um
what would you how would you want to do
you think about your everything about
like legacy or or
how you want to be remembered i don't
think about it but i went to acupuncture
i go to acupuncture once a month and and
he was like you know you got to start
thinking about that and i was like
really i just don't think that way
you have a morbid acupuncture he's not
more but he's like that's just the age
you're at where people i shouldn't talk
thinking about things like that or
legacy and i'm like oh really yes like i
don't i don't really
no think about that kind of stuff maybe
not in terms of like career or but but
in terms of uh
[ __ ] how do i
yeah okay you don't want to be
how do you ever think about how you're
you're perceived by others by i don't
but i'm not saying i never will but
maybe when he said that i'm like great
i'm gonna put that in my head and i will
start thinking about it after these ten
episodes are done and all my teeth are
out of my head but i will start i mean
it's stuff to ponder and i like that he
brought it up and i'll start thinking
about it when i need to it you know you
do when you have to but i'm not gonna
put things i must start thinking about
it now if you don't you should probably
shouldn't it's probably much healthier
not to i would imagine i mean it is for
me i don't like thinking that and then
you start overthinking and
oh yeah i don't can't yeah i'm not going
to do that um
do you ever but so you don't often do
you often think about that i mean just
death as a concept i'm not afraid of it
for sure you're not i'm not afraid of it
i'm not afraid of it
i'm afraid of it how it's going to be
like i wouldn't want to go down an
airplane like something like i that or
if it's going to hurt or suffocating or
underwater like things like that
i think about more but um
you know yeah but i'm not like oh my god
i don't want to ever die i don't think
the concept of it doesn't it doesn't
keep you awake
no wow is that bad to say no it's really
great you're you're really what are you
it's very liberating oh god cripplingly
oh really yeah i mean the idea that this
made
there will be no existence that there's
no this is all
an exercise in futility
maybe you know i mean it's wonderful it
actually if anything it's it's helped me
take stock of what is important now in
this present what is that important to
you what are the top three things that
are important to you what's the number
one thing a laughter oh laughter i think
in finding joy in life yeah yeah you
know everything you were saying about
people
and whatever that is that could be it
comes in you know depending on the
person obviously whatever you value but
i value
humor i love
you know seeing funny things like
experiencing funny things with people
is very important to me a night of
laughter that night at your house yeah
that was a fun time fun time it was just
like a pro that i more nights like that
yeah yeah it's fun getting the right
group of people together
and we will get together we'll have
another party i hope so it'll be fun
yeah but this was fun it was fun thanks
for asking me thanks for coming thanks
for coming to both locations oh you're
welcome but especially this location uh
yeah thanks
[Music]
well that happened by the way it is that
happens
well
well that happened oh god it's so funny
she was she's so funny she was uh the
way the studio was set up
she was there was a clear
there's like a clear glass window that
separated you guys from
me
and she she was like i like doing live
shows it's more it's more whatever like
interesting for me so she kept she was
playing to an audience yeah so
she kept
you were the audience
so
i was very conscious of my own uh oh
yeah my own status as an audience member
your reactions and stuff that must have
been with that must have been an
audience of one yeah
i remember because she was facing you um
and so i obviously was was not uh
couldn't see you but i i could see her
kind of glancing up and referring to you
like playing to you uh it was funny to
watch and i i i imagine that you might
have been uncomfortable as i was i was i
got over it she is uh she is so weird
and i don't mean it in a bad way you
know i mean it in the best right
possible she is such a weird you know
that word is is often used as you know
like bullies
i remember growing up i was like you're
weird you're weird i think there's a
really good weird there's a there's a
good definition of weird and she is
exactly that good definition i think so
too you know i've been doing this i keep
referencing it but i've been doing this
hosting job and hosting this kids show
and these kids are
all so unique and interesting and really
sweet funny they're great kids but um
one of them in particular was uh
always moving around and fidgeting and
like
the
director was having a hard time with him
because he he kept like turning his body
and he
he's a kid you know he was just kind of
like doing kid stuff and um i was
watching him one day and i forgot that i
had a body mic on and i was just
watching him do his project whatever
they were doing and i was like that kid
is
what a weirdo he is so weird and um
a couple minutes later one of the
producers pulled me aside and he was
like um all the parents are listening
they were all listening in the like
parents room and they heard you say that
about their their son and i
meant this and he was like i i was like
i genuinely meant it as a in a good way
yeah i meant it as a good thing but of
course
you know parents don't want to hear that
their kids are weird uh
i know i mean i guess it's gotten a bad
rap but but i think it could have that
word could
experience the same type of sort of
renaissance that the word nerd
had you know because when we were kids
calling someone a nerd or being referred
to as a nerd was 100 a negative thing
totally and now you know with bill gates
and steve jobs with the success of these
quote-unquote nerds it's it now it's
like a cool
you know maybe rick moran i mean who
else i think amy sederis should lead the
weird renaissance yeah if anyone could
tell my god yeah
yeah proudly and she would probably i
that's the thing we're saying it now and
so listeners may think mistake it as an
insult but i know that amy never would
right you know
i'm sure she knows she should be proud
of it yeah
there's something about it's she's one
of those people who
just the way she talks and the way her
face looks when she talks i know she
can't
she can't not be funny yeah she's one of
those people who i think can't not be
funny yeah that's true gaffigan was a
little bit like that yeah you know he
had a and that's why also that's one of
the limitations obviously that's the big
limitation of a podcast where you can't
somebody with such a funny expressive
face when you can't see it you're right
when you when you add the component of
her like face
and the faces she's making and like yeah
she talks a lot about her brother which
i was happy to hear because i know we're
such big fans yeah we'd love to have him
on the show at some point
but you know she comes from this pretty
big family and she was saying that
uh they're all very close and they all
really like each other and get along and
it made me so curious to because i know
how unique
and uh special she is and i know how
unique and special david is
but it made me so curious to experience
yeah the other ones and to see them
together as a family
a sedaris thanksgiving oh my god
i mean that's uh that's a show that's a
show yeah
uh at one point she said she
does the same characters also jerry
blank was kind of from her childhood
that type of character
and the and the characters she plays now
on her on her show at home with amy
sedaris she said all of those come from
uh her childhood and when she was like
five or six years old she started doing
these different characters and the fact
that she's still playing these same
characters makes sense because there's
something and again at the risk of
sounding
insulting or offensive i don't mean it
this way
there's something
uh very childlike still yeah about her
totally and there's so many and then so
once i started thinking that way uh i
was kind of
like tuned into my ears were tuned in to
hear these more child moments of
childlike moments and there were a few
examples that i uh that i wrote down one
the way she she talked about playing
with her god children and it sounds like
she plays with them not like an adult
playing with kids it kind of sounds like
she's on yeah like knows how to get on
their level and and
and and kind of be present with them on
the same level which is the best way to
play with kids i think that's the best
way to be with kids they must love her
she also in another couple examples
she loves allowance money
like a kid yes uh at one point out of
the blue and that was sincere that was
totally sincere out of the blue she
she goes how'd you get that scar on your
forehead
she was asking about the scar on your
forehead like a kid would do you know
like they notice something and they have
to ask you yeah which can be really
awkward too and it's like you know when
a kid just points something out points
out like a flaw in your face or
something well she also says that that
kids are totally non-judgmental which is
why she likes them and there's something
about like
she seems like someone if she were to
point something out about you like your
scar yeah she certainly wouldn't mean it
totally as it you know looks bad i want
to make you feel bad or anything it's
just she's curious totally sincere did
you get that scar yeah like like it i
love that about kids too i love that
which is i guess
what i love about her
also like a kid at one point she said
church is so boring you're talking about
church it's like yeah like that's how a
kid wouldn't i remember that yeah i was
boring i agree with it but i haven't
said that about church in so long
um also one more uh she she talks about
not being scared of dying but rather how
she's gonna die
which is more like that type of fear it
seems more
uh like how a kid would think about it
like i'm scared of i don't want it to
hurt i don't want to hurt exactly the
fact that she's in a way at least
maintained that type of innocence yeah
in her life
i think she's just so lucky so lucky i
you know i was watching uh the breakfast
club the other day
and uh
it was just overwhelmed by how
how beautiful it is uh and how it's all
about finding the common
humanity in one another even like you
know kids from such different cliques in
high school but there's a line in it
that like extra overwhelming and they
say when when you grow up your heart
dies do you remember that who says that
um i think ali's sheety uh when you grow
up your heart dies ally sheedy sounds
like an ally
yeah and it's just and it comes at a
moment in the movie where it's there
it's so honest that there's something so
truthful about that john hughes was a
genius i don't think he gets the credit
for being such a brilliant writer um but
also was able to tap speaking of like
not talking down to kids not talking
down to teenagers that movie talks to to
them like direct
at their level it's very um honest but
that line really struck me i haven't
been able to get out of my head when you
grow up your heart dies and there's
something about amy that is
and her
child
exuberance that is so
beautiful it's like her heart is intact
in such a wonderful way um unfortunately
we keep forgetting to make this
announcement we're so sorry we had to
cancel the three live shows that we had
planned i had an acting commitment uh
that prevented us from doing two of them
and it just felt silly to do the one um
so those philadelphia brooklyn dc shows
if you had bought tickets obviously
you're gonna get a full refund and we
are gonna
try to reschedule them for later in the
winter so
apologies uh my career got in the way
um but we are gonna reschedule hopefully
so uh be on the lookout for that and uh
before we end the show uh let's do our
our letter our letter moment
this is from stacy
g
and she uh the subject is a few emojis
uh
smiley face couple others that i don't
know how to say and the female sign
life is short and full of funny stories
hey y'all
this story is slightly embarrassing but
too funny not to share
i'm excited
i started listening to your podcast
shortly after the first episode was
released and have been listening weekly
ever since i'd forgotten how big of a
celebrity crush i used to have on justin
but listening to the show revitalized my
crush a little oh stacy
so one evening i watched he's just not
that into you and enjoyed several
glasses of wine followed by some
quote quality time
with my husband
once
turns out a crush on justin long will
get you pregnant
what
thank you both
[Music]
holy [ __ ] thank you both for doing the
podcast tuesdays are my mondays because
of my work schedule and for the first
time i look forward to tuesday each week
stacey g oh wow wow
oh wow well you're welcome baby g they
better name that kid justin that's all
i'm saying
or justine or who did i play i kind of
hope her husband doesn't hear this
because
he's going to be like wait a second
was she thinking about
i know the whole time i know was that or
maybe maybe the husband was you just got
her fired up yeah whoa you were like a
fluffer you're like his fluffer oh my
god that's that's maybe the most
flattering thing i've ever read about
myself you helped create life but the
thought of me the thought of my
me in that movie
helped get her in a place where she she
could receive her husband in a way that
created life
receive her husband
well that is so i mean i don't even know
what to say about that stacey that is uh
it's advice that we all could learn from
yeah that is
universally uh valuable yeah advice
watch he's just not an interview if you
want anyone who is looking to get
pregnant starting a family yeah do
yourself a favor either watch
he's just not that into you or tusk
or jeepers creepers if you don't want to
get pregnant yeah watch these movies
anyway thank you to everyone uh who
wrote in and continues to write in and
uh if you haven't please do at um we
want to hear from you yeah life is short
at wundery.com
well that's the show thank you guys for
listening and gals and rabbits life is
short is hosted by me justin long it's
produced by christian long and megan
monaco senior producer is michelle mish
lans our audio engineer is marcelino
via
executive producers marshall louis and
ernan lopez for wondering have a good
week
wait wait are mr
furley and roper the same person but mr
roper is like more like
rude like stolen and and
there's more personalities
do they have the same per like beliefs
yeah they're like the same i think
am i remembering wrong
i don't know they're both they both
don't like that jack is gay
is that it though but is there a role
basically like they don't look at jack's
guy or wait a minute i don't think early
minds that he's gay
does no they he hates him are you sure
what happened was two people i think
it's the same character oh you might be
right
because there was a different scene did
furley have like a horny wife
it's the same personality but one day
yes wait did furley didn't have a horny
wife i think philly was single she was
like a blanched evereau
did furley flirt with the girls no you
know what it is i think furly was kind
of gay too
oh yes
yes yeah he would be like i don't want
like
like like he kind of wants to be part of
it wait yeah by the way if i watch an
episode of that show right now it would
melt my brain
it might be on
oh
it might be on
it might be really good
but roper versus furley
you mean in a fight
no
[Laughter]
you mean just like
uh personality who would win in a fist
fight
and roper is older no roper's older for
just like he would wouldn't really would
jump around like a rabbit and like rope
it open and try to try to rope a dope
him and then like rope just like
j bum rush
[Laughter]
he is like a dopey roper
roper dope
i think furley would easily win i think
by the way i think furley even though he
had prematurely gray hair i think he was
like 20 years younger than roper i do
you were like he was much younger he
would destroy romeo didn't you wear like
pant suits and ascots yeah because that
was just the time period but i see i
think wrote i think furley was the same
that wasn't against jack and those
people and the roommates but roper was
like an elder he was like the older
generation no furley was older than
roper
i think you're out of your mind at least
out of your mind at least same age
you